[Musique]
ouf la nous voilà tout de même arriver
nous avions très peur d'être en retard
aujourd'hui car nous avions encore
beaucoup d'autres petits enfants à voir
avant vous mais fort heureusement les
vendeuses ont été très favorables
avez vous été très sage aujourd'hui
oui et j'en suis très content
petit louis et sa soeur mirabel ont eux
aussi étaient très mignons et pour les
récompenser gros ours leur a préparé un
joli jeu roewe très amusant je peux y
aller patron tu peux y aller nounours
études et embrassera bien fort de ma
part je comptais sur moi patrons eux hop
hop hop hop hop hop au jour les gentils
dit il dit honnêtement kachkar bien
cherché gros noms je vous ai préparé un
autre jeu beaucoup plus amusant ah ah
voilà mon mouchoir rouge pâle rhume on
va jouer à colin maillard les enfants
commençaient
vinci droit pour sûr c'est drôle on se
cache les yeux avec le mouchoir qu'on
attache way et il faut essayer
d'attraper les autres attendez c'est pas
tout quand on attrape quelqu'un il faut
le reconnaître sans le regarder mais
seulement en le touchant à ledeuix ah
oui oui j'ai compris bien là petit louis
approche de matelas voilà oui c'est nous
voyons des wagons pour bon bon bon
qui c'est qui commence et toiles ou non
mais tu vas mettre le foulard est là
vous voilà bien au delà août
voilà où tout le monde sait assez bien
roulement attention les jeux commencent
ce cas là on frotte aux houles alors
pour la laouve oulalalala j'ai la tête
qui tourne
si tu savais que j'y vois rien rien rien
vous devez attraper
non c'est une chaire à huy où l'on voit
pas cette fois je te tue heureux qui
sait où
où ça pique mais mais c'est un ballet
cette fois cette astuce je les attrape
attendait coca
[Musique]
ans
alors les enfants le jeu vous a plu ah
voilà nounours qui revient je laisse à
cette fois ils ne peuvent pas aller plus
loin à poplar j'obtiens un voyons voir
lequel s'est pas petit louis ce pas non
plus mirabel mais qui sait tôt c'est une
lisse le marchand de sable à l'on enlève
ton bandeau se vouent patron oui et il
tombe bien attrapé mon pauvre nigaud
oslo oui je suis un gros nigaud vous
pouvez le dire
alors en route nigaud bonne nuit les
enfants
allez vite vous coucher à demain loto
morts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
décidément mirabel et p'tit louis sont
vraiment très sage ruban j'espère que
vous aussi vous faites plaisir à vos
parents oui oui oui d'accord entendu
grand jour ce mais ne me fait pas
attendre le au nom du combat
[Musique]
moi j'avoue je me présente pas bon je
cois savate important
[Musique]
une très belle histoire que je m'en vais
vous il y avait une fois une petite
fleur appelé crocus qui habitait dans
une petite maison tout noir sous la
terre il y avait bien longtemps qu'ils
étaient là ce petit crocus depuis
l'automne et il avait très froid car
c'était l'hiver il s'ennuyait beaucoup
il était tout seul et il trouve l hiver
bien long
un jour il entendit frapper à sa porte
et docks qui est la demande intime c'est
moi la pluie qui voudraient bien entré
lui répondit une petite fille l'onho
nous on n'entre pas dit le petit crocus
et on ne le dérange a plu et pendant
très longtemps et le petit crocus
s'ennuyait chaque jour d'abord puis un
bon matin
on fera pas de nouveau à sa porte toc
toc qui est là c'est moi le soleil il
répondit un gentil petit garçon non non
on n'entre pas encore répondu andésite
ans le petit crocus puis quelques jours
plus tard
toc toc toc qui l'aiment là
c'est la pluie et le soleil
le soleil et la pluie crièrent ensemble
les deux petits enfants et nous voulons
entrer
oui si vous êtes tous les deux ensemble
je vous ouvre la porte
le petit crocus ouvrit la porte avec
beaucoup de peine car il avait encore
les mains engourdis par le froid la
pluie et le soleil entrèrent dans la
maison bonjour petit crocus la pluie lui
pris la main droite
le soleil la main gauche ils l'auraient
vite vite jusqu'en haut
et là ils lui dirent passe la tête à
travers la terre et le petit crocus
passe à sa tête et voilà il était au
milieu d'un beau jardin de n'y avait pas
encore d'autres fleurs car il était le
premier à éclore
et quand les enfants arrivent ère pour
le regarder ils se virent à chanter
bravo bravo
l'hiver est bientôt fini vive le
printemps qui approche et tous les
petits oiseaux le salut maire d'anchamps
temps et le soleil réchauffe à sa petite
tête pas l'espoir est finie ils étaient
tous hier va pas non ils avaient tous
ses amis les oiseaux près de lui et il
savait que toutes les autres fleurs à
les sortir de terre très bientôt où
l'eau je suis encore en retard je vais
me faire broder par ulysse allons les
enfants chez vous vite
au revoir à du mois
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit louis
bonnet mirabel boni tous les enfants
endormis vous vite
nous reviendrons vous voir demain bonne
nuit
à deux pas
[Musique]
oh
e
bonsoir les enfants vous voyez notre
gros ours est de plus en plus élégant et
aujourd'hui il a même apporté un
parapluie - le nom rouge parapluie c'est
un bar à jus ah oui oui c'est pour
descendre plus vite voie romaine de
petits copains regardez au fait
attention attention nounours tu vas te
faire très mal
le voile ne me revient pas puisque c'est
un parachute
attention un deux trois j'ai mes enfants
vous n'aimez pas et des mois et des mois
les offres et des mots
on va tenter en lâchant ou l'allemagne
j'ai voulu faire le mal je me suis fait
mal au poignet gauche
mais non c'est toi là bas tout le monde
on vous l avons dit oui ou non sur les
yeux ont maintenant un peu de poids
important donc non ça va mieux
non merci je peux rire elle si les
enfants
vous m'avez bien soigner chez il ne sait
plus de betty c'est promis oui les gens
procès le jury ne doute c'est comme les
grands viennent me croient pas besoin de
lire ça fera du bien même si les gens
voient
pour bourgeois vous voyez c'est très
dangereux de jouer au parachute avec un
parapluie
il ne faut jamais faire comme ressource
il aurait pu se faire encore beaucoup
plus mal eh bien mon pauvre gros jours
comment te sens-tu et ses bienfaits
une autre fois tu ne t'amuses rap lui a
sauté avec un parapluie plus assez
grande pour savoir que ça ne se fait pas
et pour donner le bon exemple allons mes
petits amis au dodo en vitesse
demain gros lot sera guérie et nous
reviendrons vous voir en avant en route
gros farceur
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
e
bonsoir mes chers petits amis mais ils
ont l'air très sage ce soir il ne se
dispute pas nounours lui aussi est sage
et il n'a pas apporté en parachute cours
aux oraux non pas trop
c'est une bonne leçon je recommencerai
plus haut va voir ce que fabrique
mirabel et petits louisien et revient
vite car nous avons encore une longue
tournée a fait compter sur moi patron je
saurai bref eux il est gros il aime
grosse voix il est très gentil il est
pas bon mais on aime bien tu sais avance
m c'est l'humour chaud à moi maintenant
les rondes vie elle est belle et pâle
comme une princesse qui dort elle habite
le ciel et ne se montre que la nuit qui
sait si need web on nettoie le support
ou écouter écouter
[Musique]
c'est la lune
il est blanc ont le même temps d'un vol
et on le boit tous les matins qui s'est
on bosse ou là on ne te seront enfin sur
la vie dans un salle des canaris tu la
connais sûrement pas il joue on le met
dans une cage et shon très bien à moi à
moi on se cache dessous
quand on joue à cache cache et on se
couche dessus quand on fait dodo qui
sert
[Musique]
encore une devinette cause oui mais la
dernière
il est sur un nuage et le jour du pipeau
il a du sable dans son sac et il
m'appelle allons les enfants il faut que
je m'en aille si l'on utilise va encore
me gronder au revoir a beaucoup qui
n'ont sa bonne marche dès maintenant
[Musique]
bonnut les enfants de très jolis rêves
embrassez vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher ouais bonsoir mirabel soir
bonsoir petit louis bros soir madame la
lune
à bientôt allons en route fidèle
compagnon route
à demain
[Musique]
oh
mon eau
[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis nous
partons tout à l'heure pour un très très
long voyage mais nous reviendrons vous
voir
oui surtout si vous êtes très gentil
avec vos parents et avec tous vos petits
camarades aux nounours n'oublie surtout
pas de dire au revoir de ma part à
mirabel est apte il use je n'oublierai
pas patron j'oublierai pro voyons et
l'aspect qu'il oui mais l'élu qu'est ce
que ça fait ça fait très bien et bea ça
fait un bain et à sa fait beau et les
bourgeons qui ne savait pas notre leçon
ça fait débat
[Musique]
les sévères 7 mètres elle si l'offre
dans la place au travail voyons re et à
sa fait oui
à madame la mairesse serra c'est bien
mon petit vous aurez une image tellement
au québec
qu'est ce que c'est ben c'est une
bouille toute ronde avec la mer autour
tout bleu et des étoiles
la caisse qui était krug osos voyage
autour de la terre
tu bois la terre c'est la boule et ça
c'est la mer le ciel les étoiles oui il
tout à l'heure que vous allez partir en
voyage vous avez sur le ciel sur la
terre nous irons tout autour de la terre
dans le ciel comme les avions comme les
nuages
et comme les ovations exactement mais
vous allez avoir fait j'ai toujours faim
[Musique]
tiens nous c'est pour toi ellis
je vous ai mis des armes ou des petits
petits championne loeb loeb diop l'homme
par qui un fromage au pommier pour toi
ou merci les enfants comme c'est gentil
quelle bonne surprise ces milices qui va
être content tu diras discours est très
sage
je dirais bien vous écrire de belles et
où vous avez ras des beaux dessins
koufra pauvres j'espère bien on a vous
reviendra vite dans un bois tu nous
racontes à votre voyage et une en
rapportera quelque chose il s'est promis
mais vous saurez bien sage et huîtres
amusement alors au dodo mènera les vous
d'auto
au revoir le cher petit à bientôt femmes
non pardon nous avons remis ce voyage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans son voyage nous allons faire
j'espère que vous aurez très sage mes
petits amis et surtout que tous les
soirs vous irez vous couchez vite vite à
l'oral en gros ours ne sois pas triste
puisque nous revenons bientôt voir petit
louis mirabel et tous nos petits et
grands amis
tu as fait le plein d'essence le moteur
marche bien alors en route
bonne nuit à tous
très très bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]
oh
bonjour les petits-enfants nous
attendons ulysse et gros source
ouais ils reviennent ce soir d'un très
long voyage et ils nous ont envoyé un
télégramme ret arrive on s'en fout de ce
soir c'est un impatient de vous revoir
lorsque mille baisers stop glisser votre
gros nounours voyais au point stop
non tu peux aussi nous avons mis toute
la maison bien au nord et nous avons été
très sage jo oui mais oui les enfants
nous revoilà relu le oui nous vous
avions promis que nous reviendrions
bientôt et vous le voyez nous sommes
revenus mais oui oui vous nous manquiez
beaucoup vous savez
avez vous été sage pendant notre absence
a pas tous les jours mais vous êtes
allez vous coucher très sagement tous
les soirs je le sais j'en tire c'est
très bien ça petit louis et mirabel gros
ours on descend vite les voies oui
patron
j'y cours oh oh oh oh pop
[Musique]
bonjour mr petits-enfants sont autant
d'atouts les jours du sommet vous avez
reçu d'autres télégrammes au moins oui
mais voilà pourquoi on était très sages
pendant votre absence et tous les soirs
tous les soirs on allait se coucher mais
je le sais c'est bien à cause de ça
qu'on est revenu car on nous regarde
on a beaucoup travaillé moi j'ai fait
plein pas ton tu vois et moi je fais des
eaux des a et des oeufs
soyez sans crainte pas trop je n'ai pas
oublié elle est bien puisque vous avez
été si sage
ouah j'ai pensé à vous les voilà des
joujoux chinois pour ti louis beaux
drago et pour me rappelle une myriade de
petites poupées chinoise bien sûr oui
[Musique]
et alors vous êtes allé chez les chinois
et si loin c'est l'ouest chinois
c'est loin très loin mais demain nous
vous raconterons tout notre voyage et
maintenant aller vite au dodo ap ap
mahmoud
c'est bien vrai ces jurés les enfants
alors dormez-vous vite
j'éteins la lumière pourquoi avoir
éliminé belle
[Musique]
28 chinois est devenu un grand dragon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans nuiton et petit ami sommes vraiment
très heureux d'être venu vous voir
car vous savez
vous nous avez beaucoup manqué mais nous
avons aussi était très heureux de
recevoir toutes les belles lettres que
vous avez écrite en fait très plaisir et
nous vous en remercions mille fois au
sens où alors en route nounours on goûte
à demain les enfants
bonne nuit dans mes vite et faites de
beaux rêves
[Musique]
e
bonsoir les petits enfants vous savez
aujourd'hui nous allons vous raconter
notre long voyage grosos vous a fait de
très beaux dessins
il n'a pas arrêté de travailler de toute
la journée jeux d seront les montrer mes
deux petits mois
je vous raconterai le voyage un tout à
l'heure à tout à l'oeuvre patrons eux eu
europe neuro
[Musique]
et bien c'est un très curieux voyage que
celui que nous avons fait en vous
quittant il y à un mois
nous avons rencontré dans le ciel un
étrange monsieur qui s'appelle monsieur
carnaval
les images c'est ça monsieur carnaval
oui c'est monsieur carnaval dans son
avion de fleurs mais oui monsieur
carnaval avec un avion tout en fleurs il
avait décidé de faire le tour de la
terre et chaque fois qu'ils arrivaient
dans une ville il y avait une fête mais
alors une fête extraordinaire pas
seulement une fête où l'on mange des
gâteaux mais une fête où tout le monde
se déguise où tout le monde danse où
tout le monde chante et où l'on jette en
l'air des confettis des pétards des
bonbons et des fleurs j'ai dit à manger
beaucoup de bonbons cause beaucoup trop
[Musique]
dans la première fête
les gens portaient des masques
extraordinaire peints de toutes les
couleurs et il marchait sur des échasses
pour est très grand il dansait dans la
rue comme de cigognes qui portent des
basques dans un autre pays
monsieur carnaval avait lui aussi mis un
masque
il voulait ressembler aux habitants de
ce pays
c'était un très joli masque de chinois
car nous étions en chine
et là nous avons vu de très grosses
bêtes en papier qu'on appelle des
dragons grosos avait un peu peur j'aime
mieux le carnaval willy avec des fleurs
oh oui le carnaval de nice où il n'y
avait que des fleurs étaient vraiment
très beau
et quand monsieur carnaval est arrivé
dans son bel avion la fête a battu son
plein la fanfare s'est mise à jouer deux
fois plus fort alors nous avons compris
que monsieur carnaval avait retrouvé son
vrai pays et c'est vrai ami il nous
sommes revenus sur notre petit nuage
vous voir ainsi que nous avions promis
c'est des fleurs du carnaval oui c'est
des fleuves de carnaval allons au dodo
maintenant que si tu es beau tout c'est
carnaval
surtout chez lui avec les flériens aussi
celui avec les dragons
oui je dormais vite à touba maintenant
ma nuit lui connu rebelles
[Musique]
et
que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les petits enfants à demain allez vite
vous coucher embrassez vos parents et en
dormez vous bien sagement au revoir
petit louis au revoir mirabel bonne nuit
à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
on
on se parlait petit ami oh la la
vous avez bien manquer de ne pas nous
voir ce soir il y à une de ces
circulations dans le ciel et nous avons
eu un mal fou pour arriver jusque chez
petit louis et mirabel
heureusement que vous m'avez pas trop
gros jour c'est un fin pilote et il
connaît bien son code de la route du
ciel mais que fondons nos deux petits
amis petit louis et me rappelle je veux
bien l'impression qu'ils ont eu aussi du
mal à circuler
je descends les guides et de mes
conseils mais ne traîne pas trop gros
ours ne fait pas attendre sur coton
[Musique]
leur boulot mais faites attention
monsieur le nounours il faut traverser
dans les passages cloutés
sinon vous allez faire avec non loin
très dangereux ces automobiles un
instant les enfants je m'en vais régler
cette circulation
[Musique]
on ne l'ont alors un petit tapir belle
doublette au sol ago à ces femmes toutes
les mamans valant chauffeur la cible est
à l'aune aux poissons aux restos
halle aux poissons
même les priorités monsieur mais je vais
à piles garde monsieur pas monsieur m
alors un orient au nom ou le vélo que
l'en but love voyons voir des lueurs des
cloches il n'y a pas de blessés drica
non jambon bon c'est l'essentiel
[Musique]
double dames avaient déjà pas les mots
je suis un mauvais agents de police dit
oui et c'est tout à fois qu'il ya un
accident vous pouviez sûr tu peux être
bon agent de police viennent bon je ne
suis pas un très bon agent de police
et bam et gaillard ou 2 go c'est que ça
sent qu'un dans le pré son réchaud
restons présents à nous allons un audit
gmi nous c'est pas tout vu de faute
ouais ouais mais tu viendra demain quand
même être très bon agent de police ah
oui bon alors à l'eau dormez vite je
viendrai de marque
jésus a dit nounours
à demain est de même chez l'agent de
police pour s'accuser nouvelle tu sais
d'accident il paie ses tics sa fausse
ouais et voilà des conducteurs qui
conduisent trop vite en toujours des
accidents il faut être prudent car on
peut se faire très mal mais je suis sûr
que vous faites tous très attention aux
mots n'ont pas trop le feu est over boni
petit louis bonnet mirabel connu des
enfants
à demain
et pour lui doucement gros ours car nous
avons encore une longue tournée à faire
[Musique]
oh
e
[Musique]
en
bonsoir les amis petit louis et mirabel
ont l'air très sage ce soir j'ai bien
l'impression qu'ils sont déjà couché
debout me méfie de ces deux petits
galope ne fait pas trop de bruit pour ne
pas les réveiller un homme ne faisait
pas peur aux bons skrull les enfants tu
sais qu'on joue on a des merveilles
ouais on à coffre à merveille assieds
toi là on va te le montrer mais mais
d'où viens-tu les têtes un grenier et
maintenant il est bien mirabel on va le
chercher lui qu'on va le chercher
quelques pistes à l'étude hier par la
pousse à peu difficile et tu prends la
poignée mirabel veuillez cliquer là oui
à l'essayer cola ou là ou là ne lâche
pas me reverras si l'on veut pas sur wii
maintenant gens qui sont avec toi
surtout pas plat allez on le pousse sur
la table
eh bien eh ben voilà ça y est l'heure
bigrement lourd qu'est ce qu'il y a deux
dents que c'est beau mais s'il ya tant
de merveilles
peut-être bien qu'au fond il y à un pot
de miel de rendement gourmands ne sait
vraiment c'était diapos voit les jolis
que kia à travers écoute le moose plus
mais mais oui on entend la mer écoute
mirabel qu'est ce que c'est
brion voir est ce que dans ce coin et il
n'y aurait pas par hasard un petit pot
de miel
énorme poussée des pigeons c'est pas du
miel au haut des bras cela et ça qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un tien des médias
guy bessette va très bien c'est vrai je
suis bon
rory on dirait roi des rois comme le roi
dagobert voit pas trop
j'ai envie
tigroux jours de mer auprès du théâtre
rue est un théâtre on chante d'accord et
moi tenons dormait bits
karine meta au revoir voilà une annonce
soit qui lui on sent les rebelles
[Musique]
on ira bel bonne les p'tits louis bonne
nuit tous les enfants en temps mais vous
vite
nous reviendrons vous voir demain
allons le roi dagobert en route bonne
nuit
bonne nuit
[Musique]
vevey montreux va donc votre vote
heureux du bon travail en aura pas ça va
tu chantes très bien gros ours
oui des enfants je ne sais pas ce qui se
prépare ce soir en tout cas notre gros
source et informez vous au jeu des
seront voir mes deux petits lobby qui
m'attendent pour faire du théâtre e up
là haut portant au gros score les au
fond j'ai apporté ma garde-robe de
théâtre
je vais vous changez la très belle
chanson monté jusqu'à 3 et le spectacle
commence
mier quoi
sur le pont d'avignon owni danseurs uni
dans sont sur le pont d'avignon monitor
surtout sans gros bébé 9 okami sein et
au métier pour ça sur le pont d'avignon
où ni quand seront ni dos ou sur le pont
d'avignon en hiver c'est tout un
c'est une belle dame mireuil si tu viens
vrai c'est là notre chef
il n'y a pas de ce chat nt pas le droit
qui le lui rend le père lui je t'écris
lui ai répondu non à michel je n'ai pas
perdu il n'est linéaire le voilà ce qu
qu'à ma bourse en battant guerre abou
s'en va-t-en guerre
ça courait jusqu'au bout mais maudit
dodeman la danse
oui trop il est passé marchande samm
d'une allée à la va-vite au dodo pauvres
grands sont bâtis guerre nous on va se
coucher tous avec les autres
[Musique]
lol ah mon dieu qu'est ce qui se passe
au segro source qui bâille retrou allons
vite nous coucher nous aussi togo
sommeil mais oui nounours et vous aussi
les petits enfants embrasser bien fort
vos parents et aller vite au dodo et si
vous êtes bien sage
nous reviendrons vous voir demain bonne
nuit
beaudoin
oh
[Musique]
bonsoir mes amis gros ours s'est fait
très beau aujourd'hui on ne trouvait pas
il est vraiment de plus en plus coquets
vers ce que le petit louis murat belles
vont faire mon portrait a tout de suite
patron a tout de suite gros sous
alors vous aussi les petits amis prenez
un crayon et une feuille de papier et
fait un beau dessin de gros source
tu vois j'ai décret de toutes les
couleurs et blanches des jaunes des
rouges des marrons et moi je vais faire
une belle photo
rocheleau jours nous allons faire votre
portrait soldats du mal à tout dit m
la mêlée a publié pour la photo ce sera
mieux
comme lundi dont moi j'ai besoin d'une
loi droit à plusieurs droits droit moi
j'aime mieux droit quasiment pas moi 6e
les bras cette oreille là un petit peu
plus rond
comment soir
voilà là plutôt les yeux des grands yeux
[Musique]
les jeunes homos face à la la comme ça
c'est pas mal encore un petit peu de
rouge sur le nez voilà attendant je me
suis dit oh ben ça y est ça va sûrement
une belle photo tu peux te mettre debout
je m'en faire une autre de boucles non
non non moi j'ai pas fini mon portrait
en couleur wallon et je mets toi de
bouzmou je fais juste une photo tu trace
one on te dit j'ai pas fini ça monte
entre en couleurs je veux rester debout
nous mêmes les enfants de bouger bien
sinon bonjour l'icône ils tous déçus
mais ils étaient tous merci pas trop
long mais offrant au lit
[Musique]
et les portraits je referai plus j'ai
compris si grosyeux fera encore temps
partrick on verra on verra à l'eau
dormez vite puis le garnement dit tu
sais vous voulez jouer je sais je sais
qu'on lui mettait tout déchirer il est
fâché au papy vous souhaitez lui et de
mirabel
[Musique]
décidément petit louis et mirabel sont
deux petits diables alors mon pauvre
nounou mon joli petit col une l'ont tous
deux sur eux si je ne t'avais pas appelé
je crois bien qu'il aurait mis toi aussi
en morceaux comme lui et vous les petits
enfants quand vous faites des portraits
j'espère que vous n'êtes plus sage que
p'tit louis et mirabel maintenant allez
vite vous coucher et faites de beaux
rêves
bonne nuit
dany boon hui
e
[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis soir nous
ne sommes pas venus voir petit louis et
mirabel hier soir pour les punir d'avoir
été méchant avec gros ours
vous vous souvenez pourquoi il me veut
dechy raymond bokole marin alors tu peux
leur téléphoner nounours demande l'heure
s'ils sont sages ce soir à tournon allô
allô allô allô merabet le petit louis
[Musique]
dépenses du pont dulys demande si vous
avez été sages promet donne moi le
téléphone nounours merci bon et bien
puisque vous avez été sages je m'en vais
vous raconter une belle histoire mais
gros ours ne descendra pas vous voir ce
soir
il viendra demain si vous allez sagement
vous coucher d'accord d'accord il y
avait une fois dans un joli chant plein
de fleurs et de hautes herbes
un joli ni plein d'abeilles et de petits
bourdon qui faisait rond quand ils
volaient il y avait un mignon petit
bourdon qui disait toujours je voudrais
aller dans une étoile
je voudrais aller dans une étoile
et voilà qu'un jour du boum boum comme
une balle qui tombait rebondi plusieurs
fois une petite étoile tomba dans le
champ mais en tombant elle se tasse à et
s'ouvrit et dedans dormez la plus jolie
petite abeille qu'on ait jamais vu
elles étaient toutes dorées comme le
miel est petit petit
quand elle se réveilla elle fut très
étonnée de se trouver au milieu de
fleurs entouré de bourdons et d'abeilles
qu'elle ne connaissait pas ses nouveaux
amis furent très gentil pour elle et lui
faire visiter le pays
le petit bourdon ne la quittait pas il
était plein d'admiration envers une
demoiselle abeilles en provenance d'une
étoile et il volé ensemble de fleur en
fleur
mais la petite abeille était triste car
elle avait l'habitude de vivre au milieu
des étoiles et elle voulait retourner
voir sa maman qui habitait dans une
grande étoile et ses frères et soeurs
qui habitait de petites étoiles et un
jour qu'elle dormait posé sur un
coquelicot ronron le petit bourg dont
amena tous ses amis et prenant le
coquelicot chacun par un pétale ils
s'envoient l'air très vite dans le ciel
pour aller tout en haut
au pays des étoiles
[Musique]
la petite haderer retrouve à toute sa
famille qui adopta ronron le petit
bourdon qui avait toujours rêvé de vivre
au milieu des étoiles
[Musique]
oh merci pour la belle histoire lice
bonne nuit qui marchandent sable on est
mené nos fins de mois
[Musique]
on est petit louis bony mirabel
bonne nuit à tous les enfants allez vite
vous couchez embrasser bien fort vos
parents et faites de beaux rêves
à demain à 12 mois
e
[Musique]